(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
TUMBLR IS A PLATFORM THAT
MAKES IT INCREDIBLY EASY TO SET
UP A BLOG, EVEN IF THERE'S
REALLY NO EARTHLY REASON THAT
THAT BLOG NEEDS TO EXIST.
SO WE'LL GIVE YOU A CHOICE OF
TWO RIDICULOUS TUMBLRS, YOU HAVE
TO GUESS WHICH ONE IS REAL.
WHICH ONE IS REAL, OKAY?
SO THIS FIRST ONE, IS IT:
"TURDS OF PORTLAND, PICTURES
OF FECES ON THE STREETS OF
PORTLAND".
(LAUGHTER)
A LITTLE P.O.O. IN THE P.D.X.
OR "JUDGE DREADS, PHOTOS OF
JAMAICAN JUDGES WITH
DREADLOCKS"?
MIKE LAWRENCE?
>> I'M GOING TO GO WITH JUDGE
DREADS, ALTHOUGH I DON'T THINK
TUMBLR HAS EVER BEEN MADE BY
ANYONE WHO CAN PHYSICALLY
TUMBLE.
>> Chris: THE CORRECT ANSWER I'M
SORRY WAS TURDS OF PORTLAND.
>> OF COURSE.
OF COURSE.
>> Chris: YOU CAN TELL THAT POOP
IS SO HIPSTER IT WON'T EVEN CURL
UP.
"WHATEVER".
>> I HEARD THAT TURD HAS RICH
PARENTS BUT HE CHOSE TO LIVE ON
THE STREET.
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: (BLEEP) WAY POINTS,
JEN KIRKMAN.
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
SO GOOD!
ALL RIGHT.
NEXT ONE?
IF BABIES HAD PUPPY HEADS OR
PUPPIES HAD BABY HEADS?
JEN KIRKMAN.
>> I THINK IT'S IF PUPPIES HAD
BABY HEADS.
>> Chris: NO.
IT'S IF BABIES HAD PUPPY HEADS.
(LAUGHTER)
>> WAIT.
THAT'S WHO IS LEAVING TURDS ALL
OVER PORTLAND.
>> Chris: IF CONFESSION BEAR IS
YOUR SOUL THIS IS WHAT MY SOUL
LOOKS LIKE.
>> THAT'S WHAT YOU GET FOR
PLAYING DOG!
(LAUGHTER)
>> Chris: THAT'S THE DYSLEXIC
GENETICIST?
>> YES.
>> Chris: ALL RIGHT, NEXT ONE.
"GIRLS WITH HITLER MOUSTACHES"
OR "WHAT IF ADELE WAS
MRS. DOUBTFIRE"?
JEN KIRKMAN?
>> I KNOW I'M RIGHT.
I KNOW I'M RIGHT.
WHAT IF ADELE WAS
MRS. DOUBTFIRE?
>> Chris: THAT'S RIGHT
WHAT IF ADELE WAS MRS.
DOUBTFIRE?
(LAUGHTER)
(CHEERS AND APPLAUSE)
BONUS, BUILDING OFF THAT, ALSO
IMAGINED "WHAT IF NIC CAGE WAS
MRS. DOUBTFIRE?"
(LAUGHTER)
"I DON'T KNOW.
JUST A WEIRD BRUSH LADY HERE TO
HANG OUT WITH THE KIDS.
THERE'S CLUES ON THE MONEY."
>> WAIT, WAIT, ISN'T THAT WHAT
THAT MOVIE WAS?
(LAUGHTER)